Just in time for our last class,
we get this in yesterday's New York Times and all over the rest of the media.
A new planet,
uh,
could be earth.
Like,
you know,
every time they get a new planet,
it's always earth like,
but this one might really be true.
Um,
it's,
uh,
found it was found by the standard doppler shift method,
which you guys all remember and,
uh,
turns out to be the lowest mass planet that's been discovered in that particular
way.
And so as a kind of final farewell calculation,
I thought we'd check the New York Times,
his numbers on this,
go back and read the article for yourself.
Uh,
the information given there is that the orbital period is about 13 days.
the distance between the planet and its star,
that's a,
the semi major axis is given as 7 million miles.
These are of course,
not the world's best set of unit.
Uh,
the distance to the system is 20 light years.
That's really close.
Somebody quoted in the article is saying,
you know,
we could go there.
Uh,
not so much.
uh,
and the,
I looked up,
the apparent magnitude of this starch turns out to be about 10.5.
Um,
and so what can we do with,
with information of this kind?
Uh,
well let's first put this into some kind of same set of units here.
13 days is something,
let's see.
Three days is a three and a half days would be a 1% of a year.
So this is like three times 10 to the minus two of a year,
uh,
7 million miles.
Uh,
that's something like 10 million kilometers and to the seven kilometers,
which is 10 to the 10 meters.
So that's something like seven times 10 to the minus two astronomical units.
And,
and,
and you know right away what to do with that,
or at least you will if you go back in your notes for a few months.
Uh,
this is in good units to use a cube depots,
p squared.
M m then shows up in solar masses.
So let's figure out the mass of this star.
Let's see,
uh,
seven times 10 to the minus two cubed divided by three times 10 to the minus two
squared.
That'll be the mass and solar masses.
Uh,
seven times seven is 50 times seven is 350 a times 10 to the minus six over 10
times 10 to the minus four.
That's 35 times 10 to the minus 2.35,
which is a third.
Okay?
Okay.
So this star is a third of the mass of the sun,
perfectly respectable mass for a start to be.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
let's see.
Let's do something else.
Uh,
it's 20 light years away.
Yeah,
20 light years.
Uh,
that's,
uh,
something like six parsecs.
So it's really nearby.
Uh,
as these things go,
not that you would want to take a space ship and,
and,
and go there or anything,
but it is one of the closer stars.
And then we can do this thing.
Uh,
we can figure out the absolute magnitude of this star I had written down the
apparent magnitude.
So that's dad equation.
Uh,
let's see,
five times the log of six tenths.
Let's call that two times three times 10 to the minus one.
Yeah,
that's six tenths,
uh,
five.
And then you know,
this thing about logs,
if you multiply them inside the bracket,
you can add them outside the bracket.
So this is log of two plus log of three,
uh,
plus log of 10 to the minus one,
log of 10 to the minus one is minus one and the other two I happened to know the
log of two is 0.3.
The log of three is 0.5 minus one.
That's five times minus 0.2 is minus one.
Uh,
and so 10.5 minus the absolute magnitude minus one.
Let's see,
how's this going to work?
This has to go over there.
That has to come over here.
Uh,
absolute magnitude.
11.5.
Now you may remember that the son,
uh,
has a magnitude and absolute magnitude of around five.
So this is much,
much fainter than the sun.
That's good because it's less massive than the sun and low mass stars get faint
really quickly.
How much fainter when we know how to do that.
Right?
Um,
let's see.
That looks in the easiest format.
It looks like this,
uh,
m star minus M son is equal to B star over be son.
Uh,
guess a minus sign out in front here.
Yes.
Uh,
so that 10 to the minus two fifths,
a 11.5 minus five a which is equal to 10 to the minus two fifths of 6.5.
All right,
what are we gonna do about that?
6.5 over 65 over five is 13.
So this is uh,
10 to the minus a 1.3 times to 2.6.
You could work it out,
uh,
and that in turn is equal to remember this is B star over B Sun,
brightness of the star,
of the brightness of the sun that tend to the 0.4 times 10 to the minus three,
three plus minus three plus 0.4 minus 2.6.
Uh,
and that's all,
I don't know what,
um,
2.5 had a guest a times 10 to the minus three,
a tiny fraction of the brightness of the sun.
Less than 1% as bright as the sun.
And this is the importance of the discovery because it's in a 13 day orbit.
It's really quite close to,
uh,
to the star.
We figured out how close it's 7%.
The distance,
uh,
of the earth to the,
of the earth to the sun is this planet from its star,
but the stars much,
much fainter too.
And so if you do the little calculation,
which is quite straight forward to do,
we won't do it here of how much energy this planet receives from its star
compared to the amount of energy that the earth receives from the Sun.
You get almost exactly the same answer.
So here is a planet,
uh,
whose surface temperature is likely to be quite similar to that of earth.
Here is a planet where liquid water could exist.
Now we don't actually know that much about this planet except for it's math.
It's five times the mass of the sun.
Oh,
sorry,
five times the mass of the earth.
That could be either a big earth or a small Neptune.
Uh,
and those are quite different objects and we don't really know,
uh,
what category from that point of view it's in,
it seems unlikely that it would be a big earth because this is a low mass star.
It's also,
as it turns out,
a low medalists city star,
so it's got only a third of the stuff of the sun,
uh,
and it's got less than half the frequency of heavy materials as the sun.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
it's hard to imagine it could build up a rocky planet five times bigger than the
earth,
but you never know stranger things then that have happened.
Uh,
and,
uh,
will probably happen again in astronomy.
So you don't know what will happen with this one?
There's rumors going around.
I should say that there are even more entertaining.
Planet's going to be announced in the next few weeks.
So keep your eye on the newspapers.
Uh,
there may in fact be more to come.
Okay.
So that's,
uh,
the last calculation here and you're just never know when these things will show
up in the newspaper.
Okay.
What we're going to do on Monday and Tuesday.
We're going to do this a double strength section.
Sorry,
Monday and Wednesday.
Thank you.
[inaudible] we decided not to do the Tuesday one.
Uh,
we've got you guys all sectioned.
I think there was an email yesterday which told you what section you're in.
If you're having any problems with that,
you know,
make sure we know about it in advance.
Uh,
and uh,
later,
uh,
well probably Saturday or so,
I will post a three pages of instructions.
You don't have to read them particularly carefully,
but I would like you to download them and print them and to bring them with you,
uh,
to the class.
Uh,
let me take you through the first page of this.
here we go.
Cosmology the game.
Uh,
and uh,
let me just take you through the sequence of place so you know approximately
what will happen.
Uh,
so at the start of the game,
everybody gets a role.
Uh,
you can be a junior or senior scientist at one of several competing scientific
institutions or a member of the Review Committee that decides which projects to
do.
Each of the competing institution then proposes a project and a funding request.
Uh,
the senior scientist has to present the case.
the review committee fan gets to decide.
And so you can't do all of them.
You can only do some of them.
Uh,
so the review committee decides what projects to approve and they,
and they give either partial or full funding,
uh,
and then they report why they have made the decisions.
They make a,
and then we tell you what the results of that scientific,
uh,
exploration is.
So,
you know,
you go out and you try and find more supernovae and we tell you that I don't
know what happens magically.
All the supernovae have disappeared or they're all way,
way,
way too bright or whatever it is that the answer turns out to be a,
and then,
you know,
a little bit more about the universe at that point.
The Review Committee,
which is made up of aging pundits all die off.
Uh,
the senior scientist are promoted to the room review committee.
The junior scientist are promoted to a senior scientists and the review
committee are reborn as junior scientist or something like that.
And so we sort of cycle through all the roles and you keep going through these
cycles until you figure out what the dark matter and what the dark energy is.
A.
And then at the end,
uh,
we will,
sort of debrief and decide what the key moment of discovery was.
An award,
a suitable simulation of the Nobel prize.
Uh,
it was m and m's last year.
we'll see.
Uh,
so that's approximately what's going to happen.
And the key thing is what kind of projects can you propose?
And the other two pages of this handout are going to be a list of potential
projects that you can propose.
You can also propose anything else you can think of and we will invent results
on the spot,
uh,
for any other kinds of projects that get approved as well.
But I figured it would be a good idea for you to have at least a range of
possibilities of things you might consider proposing and why.
So that will be posted on Saturday.
Uh,
my experiences that in a,
in a just under two hours,
you can figure out all the secrets of the universe in this particular well,
well,
the universe that I designed,
which is a,
you know,
not as sophisticated perhaps as the real universe will turn out to be a okay
procedural questions on any of that.
Yes.
Who knows,
since I don't know what the actual universities,
it would be a little hard to give you the actual university as an exercise.
Uh,
what I have done is I have invented a universe which is consistent with
everything we know now,
uh,
and has many more answers than we know now.
Uh,
I,
it would,
I would be very,
very fortunate indeed if that turned out to have anything to do with the real
universe.
So,
uh,
I wish it were true that I have those kinds of powers.
Uh Huh.
But it's possible.
That's the key.
Um,
other questions?
Okay.
So,
uh,
last time we ended on kind of an optimistic note.
Uh,
I had written down this plot,
which was a plot of Omega lambed up versus Omega matter going from zero to one
and beyond.
And uh,
I put down,
uh,
I showed you the plot of three lines on this plot,
which is the lines indicated by different kinds of cosmological observations.
So the supernovae,
which we've talked about a lot,
um,
force you to be on a line,
something like that in the plot.
So this is where the supernovae observation,
uh,
kind of forces you to be.
And then the,
um,
uh,
observations of the cosmic microwave background force,
the sum of these two quantities to be one.
And so you end up with something that looks like that from the cosmic microwave
background.
And then by comparing simulations of the growth of cloud,
of,
of clustering to the actual,
uh,
clusters of galaxies that we observe in the universe,
there turns out to be a third line and it looks like this.
So this comes from,
uh,
clustering that legible.
Yeah,
close enough.
Um,
okay.
And so the great thing about this was if you will recall that there were three
different lines on a two dimensional graph and they all clock cross at the same
point.
And this constitute to test of the theory because it is not necessarily true
that if you put down three lines at random in a two dimensional space that they
will all cross at the same point.
And so the fact that they do makes you think that something about how we
understand what's going on is going pretty much right because,
uh,
there's no reason for these things to,
to cross it a point we predict that they do because you know,
they're all measuring the same universe but in different ways.
And so the fact that they do a lend some credence to this whole,
uh,
a wonderful set of stories.
But there's another way of looking at this plot,
which is to look at what these axes are.
What are we actually plotted on this plot?
This Omega that shows up is the ratio of the density of something to the
critical density of the universe.
So this is,
this access is effectively the density of the dark matter.
And this axis here is the density of the dark energy.
So what we are plotting in this wonderful plot where everything works out so
nicely is the density of something we don't know anything about versus the
density of some other thing that we don't know anything about.
Uh,
and so in a certain sense,
the fact that we're working,
regardless of where the lines are,
the fact that we've got these two axes means we don't have any idea what's going
on.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
perhaps the more pessimistic view,
and uh,
uh,
you know,
thinking about this,
you get a kind of faint odor of epicycles.
Remember epicycles epicycles I talked about in the very first class if very
first lecture of this class,
this was this business,
uh,
back in the Middle Ages where they thought the earth was still the center of the
universe and they were trying to figure out what was going on with the orbits of
the planets.
Uh,
and they discovered that a single circle for each planet didn't do the job.
It didn't Conchord with what,
uh,
what the observations were.
So they said,
all right,
well,
you know,
the center of the universe and we know everything has to be circle.
So we'll put circles on top of circles.
And then they were able to match the observations,
but then the observations got better and they had to have ever more complicated,
uh,
circles on top of circles.
So,
uh,
let me,
so that was the story of epicycles back in the Middle Ages.
And then of course what it turned out is that the idea that the earth was the
center of the universe in the idea that everything goes in circles of just
wrong.
And as soon as you abandoned those two ideas and have the idea that the planet
to go in ellipses around the sun,
all of a sudden everything gets much simpler.
And it's all explained well.
So what's happening in cosmology now?
We're observing the motions of galaxies and objects within galaxies like
supernovae that we can see.
The first thing we found out is that the rotation of galaxies and other
indicators of matter don't,
are,
aren't in accord with what we expect.
So we invent dark matter to explain the internal motions of galaxies and galaxy
clusters.
We then discover that the external motion,
the motion of these things through the universe,
uh,
also doesn't accord with what we would have expected.
So we invent dark energy in order to explain that.
So we've now in the past 25 years,
invented to complete two different but completely imaginary,
uh,
um,
as far as we know,
uh,
concepts to fill,
96% of the universe with,
to uh,
figure out,
uh,
what's going on with the fact that the motions we observe her,
not the emotions we expect.
How many more,
you know,
let's go out and measure some more things,
then maybe we'll need dark,
something else,
uh,
and dark,
something else after that.
Uh,
and maybe it needs to change with time and maybe it needs to magically appear
halfway through the history of the universe or something like that.
Who knows?
You know,
if you keep infant tick these things,
of course you can explain anything you like Justin,
exactly the same way that if you have enough epicycles you can have a model with
the earth at the center of the universe that explains all the motions of the
planets.
You see.
You know,
if you get to just keep inventing words here,
uh,
of course you can explain the universe and you know,
what would have happened if this line didn't come across.
Supposing that line had been out there,
what would you have done,
what you would have said as well.
Of course we don't understand dark energy.
So we've just proved that dark energy varies with time or varies spatially or
uh,
becomes opaque at large distances or some other quantity quality.
And then we would have rewritten this graph so that they do cross a,
that's not very compelling.
Um,
and indeed,
uh,
it has gotten sufficiently embarrassing that there is now just beginning to be a
feeling that maybe what's going on is we need new laws of physics.
Maybe we're at a moment,
like the end of the 16th century or the end of the 19th century where the
current basic ideas that we base our,
our,
our theories of the universe are,
are about to be a radically transformed.
That's possible.
It's also possible,
you know,
that we'll wake up three years from now and seeing the newspaper that someone
has discovered what the dark matter is and that three years after that we will
wake up and read in the newspaper.
Uh,
that some scientists have developed a good string theory that entirely predict
exactly how the dark energy is going to behave.
I think in general,
it's always a good idea to bet on standard physics,
uh,
rather than revolutionary new ideas.
But if you keep at it for a quarter of a century as we have in looking for the
dark matter and keep finding nothing,
uh,
you got to start to wonder.
Uh,
and indeed there was,
uh,
a,
a radical theory proposed a few years back about the dark matter in particular
that there is no dark matter.
It's just we don't understand the laws of gravity.
And so,
you know,
we had to modify the laws of gravity for very high gravitational fields that
turned out to be relativity.
And they suggested that you also need to modify the laws of gravity for very low
gravitational fields,
the kinds of things you feel at the edge of the galaxy from the galaxy.
Uh,
and they figured out how you would have to do that in order to explain,
uh,
the orbits of galaxies without using any dark matter.
This was called Mond for a modified Newtonian dynamics.
Uh,
and I don't think that party,
it's become clear that that particular theory probably isn't going to go
anywhere for various reasons.
It doesn't seem to be self consistent.
But nevertheless,
this was seriously proposed.
It was also,
I have to say a little philosophically dubious because if you want a new theory
of gravity,
you don't want to go back to Newton and start over again.
You probably want to start with relativity and move on.
Uh,
but they made it consistent with relativity.
They worked out all the,
uh,
all the stuff and it seemed to work okay.
Except it turns out it disagrees with observations also.
Um,
but it was a real attempt to,
uh,
imagine that these things might really turn out to be epicycles.
And if,
if there isn't progress in finding out what's going on,
I think we're gonna see more of that,
uh,
as time goes on.
Uh,
and uh,
it may be than in 50 years.
These things will look like a,
what we think about people who thought that the earth was the center of the
universe.
So we'll see.
Now there is one additional thing that we know about the universe.
Uh,
in addition to,
you know,
these three lines,
which are kind of the basic information that we,
we currently have.
Uh,
and that is,
so here's another fact about the universe.
Uh,
kind of an obvious one.
the fact is that we exist,
otherwise we wouldn't be having this conversation.
Right?
Uh,
and,
uh,
what does that tell you about the universe?
It tells you,
uh,
the fact that life exists,
and in particular,
uh,
what we grandiosely refer to as intelligent life exist.
Um,
let's see.
Uh,
what does,
what do you require the universe to have if life is going to exist?
It needs a couple of things even,
you know,
and we can get into a whole argument about life as we know it and whether you
can make it out of silicon instead of out of carbon or whether you're going to
have life made entirely out of neutrons on the surface of a neutron star or
something like that.
Uh,
but uh,
no matter how you slice it,
it's got to have some complexity to it.
Uh,
you've got to have a lot of moving parts.
One way or another.
You have to have information flowing back and forth.
You can't make a,
a living creature out of nothing but helium atoms.
Helium you may remember from,
from chemistry,
isn't,
is a noble gas.
It doesn't interact.
It can't form structures.
Uh,
and if you had nothing but helium,
there would certainly be no life because they're just be a bunch of helium atoms
that don't interact with each other.
If you made the universe entirely out of Wimps,
weakly interacting massive particles that just kind of fly past each other and
don't pay any attention to each other,
you're not gonna have anything,
uh,
like life because there's no complexity.
It probably also need some time to evolve.
Uh,
it took a while,
a,
if you start,
you know,
there's this wonderful experiment where you take a whole bunch of stuff that was
supposed to be in the oceans of the early Earth,
uh,
and you put it in an atmosphere of carbon dioxide and you keep sending
electricity through a m simulating lightning strikes.
If you keep at that for long enough,
you can make,
you can make things that,
uh,
that seemed like some of the simpler amino acids.
Uh,
so you just keep flashing lightening at the,
at the ocean and you hope that you eventually you build up life of life.
Maybe yes,
maybe no,
but certainly it takes a long time.
And once you have somehow magically out of this process,
self replicating viruses or something like that,
then you got to stick around for a few billion years while evolution takes hold.
And makes bigger and bigger and more and more complex structures.
So you have to have a certain amount of time to,
to allow this process to go forward.
Uh,
so,
uh,
for example,
supposing it were true that Omega Lambda,
that's the density of the dark matter of the dark energy was great.
Instead of being around 0.7 was greater than a hundred.
So the whole universe is being pushed apart by this stuff and there's hundreds
of times more of it than there is in the current universe.
You're not going to form any structure.
We looked at the formation of structure last time.
You just push the universe apart really fast and you never get galaxies or stars
or anything like that because there's too much dark energy to let them congeal.
Uh,
so push universal part,
no structure.
So that would be a university that's very unlikely to have any kind of
complexity or in any kind of life because you just take all these individual
particles and push them far away from each other.
Uh,
supposing it were true that the density of matter is significantly less than 10
to the minus two.
So instead of having a third,
the critical density,
it has less than 1% of the critical density,
then you've got nothing to form the structures with.
Uh,
and so the same thing happens also no structure.
on the other hand,
if the,
uh,
if the matter density is,
is way up about in the thousands or the millions in this kind of scale,
then everything collapses right away back into a black hole.
And again,
there isn't a lot of structure in a black hole.
It's one single point in the,
in,
in the center of the event horizon.
So,
uh,
we have no way of knowing what these numbers should be.
But what we do know is that we are fortunate that they adapted to be in the a
relatively narrow range because if they weren't,
we wouldn't exist.
Uh,
this turns out to be true of most of the constants of nature.
for example,
here's another example.
The Schwartz Shield radius.
Remember the Schwartz showed radius the event horizon of black hole,
uh,
given by two g m oversee square.
Now supposing you lived in a universe in which Ge,
the constant of gravity was substantially bigger than it is in our universe.
If Ge were bigger and supposing you in that same universe,
see the speed of light,
we're a good deal smaller than it is in our universe.
Uh,
just some other,
pick some other values out of a hat such that this is true.
Then the Schwartz showed radius associated with any given mass would be bigger
because both g is bigger,
C is bigger.
And then for the same amount of mass,
you get a big swatch of radius.
So now think about what happens if the Schwartz Shield radius is bigger than the
radius of a white dwarf.
Then you never get white dwarfs are neutron stars.
You'd go see all stars evolve when they run out of nuclear fuel.
Straight into black holes,
then all stars.
Yeah,
and as black holes.
And the consequence of that is that the carbon that is made in stars is never
just into the universe and you never end up with planets because the next
generation of stars is still made out of pure hydrogen.
And helium,
just like the first generation of stars was.
And you never end up with enough heavy element with any heavy elements.
And so you can't form planet,
so no carbon or anything other than hydrogen and helium,
uh,
and you're not going to make life out of,
out of hydrogen gas and helium.
Uh,
now,
uh,
carbon,
of course with this fabulous substance,
uh,
does all this wonderful chemistry at forms,
rings,
does all this great stuff.
That's why organic chemistry,
which is the chemistry of carbon is more complicated than the whole rest of all
the other elements,
chemistry of all the other elements put together.
Uh,
and so the properties of carbon are very,
very important for allowing complex structures to exist.
Uh,
so properties of carbon.
And it turns out that if you very,
uh,
would,
disappear or not be able to support these complex chains and,
and complex carbon chemistry with disappear,
if,
uh,
the constants of nature and in particular something called the fine structure
constant,
uh,
was even slightly different.
It also turns out you couldn't make the carbon in the first place because
there's a property of,
uh,
the way the energy levels work in an atom that allows,
the reaction of three helium atoms to fuse into a carbon atom atom to occur fast
enough for the act that,
uh,
that reaction to actually take place in by substantial amounts.
So it wouldn't take much messing around with,
uh,
with the constants of nature to make,
um,
to make carbon either not exist or have different kinds of properties.
You know,
if carbon turns out to be just like iron,
uh,
and it just kind of sits there,
you're again going to have some trouble creating any kind of complex life.
Uh,
so we have this odd situation in which it appears that drastic,
really quite drastic fine tuning,
uh,
of natural Constance
is a prerequisite for life.
So not any set of constants will do.
In fact,
if you picked a random bunch of numbers for all these constant,
almost certainly that would be a universe with no complexity in it at all.
And this gives rise to a set of ideas called a general leaving anthropic
principle,
which is kind of the idea that,
uh,
the fact that life exists and people in particular
is important
for understanding physics,
for understanding basic physics.
And the way I've just stated that,
you know,
that seems kind of obvious,
right?
Uh,
of course it has to be true that the universe is such that we can exist because
we know we exist and we're the ones who were studying the universe.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
just in that form,
it's not very interesting,
but the implications of it lead you,
uh,
in a wide variety of different philosophical,
direction.
So,
uh,
the question is why
do all these constants GVC lambda,
what have you,
uh,
have the values they do?
Okay.
So,
uh,
as I said,
there are a wide variety of different kinds of categories of answers to this.
One is that it's just a big accident,
you know,
uh,
whatever it was that set these numbers,
happened to pick a set of numbers that allows life to exist.
And there's nothing to talk about because it's just a complete accident.
Uh,
and it could just have easily have picked out some other numbers.
And,
uh,
even though most sets of numbers don't allow for the existence of life,
the one that is the set of numbers that were somehow determined,
uh,
by whatever mechanism determined them just kind of by accident,
produced a set of numbers that allows complexity to exist,
not very satisfying,
uh,
approach,
because among other things,
if that's true,
you're thinking stops dead right at that point.
If you can attribute everything to accident,
you know,
you just go on with your life.
Um,
another sort of the opposite of this is to say it happened on purpose,
uh,
life created if you want to use that or the constants of nature that allow life
to exist are created on purpose.
Yeah.
And there's,
you know,
an obvious,
uh,
religious,
sub category here where you say that there is a creator,
a god of some kind who did this on purpose.
Uh,
so this leads,
uh,
to various kinds of religious explanations.
But,
uh,
in,
in more general terms,
uh,
it doesn't have to be religious.
This is what's called the strong anthropic principle,
which says that for some reason,
be it be it religion or anything else,
uh,
that,
the universe must
yeah.
Have life or have the set of,
uh,
of constants that allows life to exist.
Um,
you know,
one of the things that the physicists are trying to do is to figure out where,
why these numbers have the values they do.
Maybe it turns out that,
uh,
if you finally work out the final theory of physics and everything,
that will tell you what these numbers have to be.
And there's only one choice that you can't choose randomly from these numbers.
That there's some theory that underlies it,
that requires you to pick certain numbers and that those numbers,
uh,
in turn,
require the existence of life.
Uh,
uh,
that's,
and whether or not you attribute that a to religious causes it,
it doesn't make a difference to the,
to the sort of a structure of this kind of argument that there's only one way
you could have made the universe somebody phrase this,
it might've been Einstein,
I don't remember.
Praise.
It is the question is did God have a choice?
Uh,
could you have made a self consistent universe with some other set of numbers?
Maybe not.
Uh,
but the,
uh,
virgin,
the,
uh,
approach to this,
which is getting the most attention at the moment,
uh,
by the kinds of people who think about these things is the concept of the
multiverse
universe is one universe.
Multiverse is many.
So the idea is that there are many universes,
uh,
with different,
yeah.
Uh,
sets of constants,
sets of numbers,
numbers and laws.
Well,
if that's true,
then things are pretty straightforward.
If you've got a a hundred Gillian universes of out there and each one has a
different set of laws at different manifestation of,
uh,
of the laws of nature,
then it's not surprising that the one we live in happens to be conducive for our
existence because,
uh,
there's a whole bunch of other ones out there that,
that there are no people in.
Uh,
and uh,
naturally we exist in one case where,
uh,
where we can,
you know,
uh,
how this works.
It's like going out into a parking lot and you see a license plate out in the
parking lot and,
uh,
the license plate is three Oh eight BJ six or something like that.
And you say,
Gosh,
what a coincidence.
Out of all the license plates in the universe,
that one happens to be sitting right in front of my office.
But if,
of course,
if it was any other license plate,
he would have said the same thing.
And so that's actually not surprising.
Uh,
so similarly,
if you have a whole lot of cards in of universe in the world,
if you have,
there are a whole lot of cars in the world,
right?
There's billions of cars in the world.
What are the odds that you get into the one you own?
Uh,
well,
pretty high,
right?
But yes,
you're doing it on purpose.
Similarly,
if there's lots and lots of different universes,
each one with a different set of physics,
what are the odds that we exist in one that allows us to exist,
uh,
pretty high.
Um,
but the question is where'd,
while these universes come from?
Uh,
and so how do you generate,
uh,
many different universes?
Why wouldn't you be satisfied with just having the one you've got?
Um,
and so again,
there are a number of different sub categories here.
There's the one in which you look beyond the cosmic horizon.
Now,
the cosmic horizon,
you know,
if the universe is 13.7 billion years old,
we can't see anything more than 13.7 billion light years away.
And in fact,
the further away we look,
we look back in time.
So we certainly don't know anything about what something 13.
What about something 15 big light years away is do we now?
And so you could imagine that there are kind of slow changes in the constants
and laws of nature and that by the time you're a hundred billion light years
away from us,
it,
that part of the universe which is causally disconnected from our own,
has some other kind of physics that is going on.
And so you postulate an infinite universe of which we can only detect ever in
principle,
a tiny fraction.
And over there somewhere there's another set of constants going on.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
there's another,
another set of physics far away that we know nothing about.
So that's one option.
Another option is other dimensions.
Those of you who have read any of the popular accounts of string theory may be
aware that one of the problems or perhaps advantages,
well,
uh,
the computer scientists call these features,
of string theory is that you require either nine or 10 or 11 or perhaps 26
spatial dimensions in order to make it work out.
Then they do this clever thing where they say,
of course we live in a three dimensional unit in university,
but it's really a 10 dimensional universe with seven dimensions rolled up so
tight.
You can't see them,
uh,
kind of a dubious proposition,
but it works out.
It actually works out quite well mathematically.
Uh,
but you could imagine,
imagine that you're in a two dimensional universe and here's your universe,
but it's embedded inside some additional spacial dimension.
There could be another two dimensional universe down here and you would have no
way of interacting with it.
And so you could imagine that these extra dimensions that are being postulated
allow the existence of many different three dimensional universes.
It's kind of next to each other,
spread out in these higher dimensions.
Uh,
and perhaps they don't all have to be three dimensional universes.
They can be other kinds of,
I mean,
that's another crucial number,
right,
is how many spatial dimensions your universe has.
Um,
and so one could imagine that a,
these kinds of extra dimensions talked about quite seriously by the string
theorist.
Um,
allow the existence of many different universes with different physical laws to
choose from.
There's also a kind of evolutionary argument.
Okay.
Uh,
this is presented in a popular book by a guy named Lee Smolin,
which is wonderful book.
Uh,
why don't you read it?
he,
his thought is that each time,
and,
and this came up,
I think earlier in the,
in,
in the class,
each time you make a black hole inside the event horizon,
a new universe forms.
Uh,
so that's one way of doing this.
So new universes,
uh,
form from old ones,
from black holes or whatever.
Uh,
and supposing you postulate that each daughter universe has slightly different
parameters,
but only slightly different from its parent in the way that each of us has a
genetic material that closely related but not identical to that of each of our
parents.
Well,
uh,
what happened you then favor in the idea that you make them out of black holes.
You favor universes that produce lots of black holes.
Uh,
and so there's a,
there's a kind of,
uh,
survival of the fittest,
not just for organisms,
but for whole universes.
If you're the kind of universe that produces lots of black holes,
you're going to have lots of children.
Then after,
after this goes on for a long time,
most of the universes in the multiverse,
uh,
will be the kinds of universes that produce lots of black holes.
How do you make black holes?
You make the most black holes by producing lots and lots and lots of stars.
Stars are complex objects.
This is the kind of universe that you're likely to end up with life in.
And so small,
it's argument is,
uh,
that,
because of this survival of the fittest for universities as a whole,
uh,
you're almost guaranteed in any particular university you pick out as the kind
of universe that will produce lots of black holes and therefore lots of
complexity and therefore we'll support life.
Uh,
and there,
there are various other versions of this same kind of thing.
And this is an attempt to kind of use the biological arguments for how you get
complexity.
Uh,
on,
uh,
a cosmological scale.
There's a difference.
Of course in the case of biology,
we get to go back and look at the fossil record and we also understand genetics
so that we know how the small modifications are created.
I mean you need a set of physical laws here that tell you how different one
universe is from its parents.
And of course that is not something we have any understanding of or knowledge of
a,
and
yes,
whole multiverse concept is now getting a lot of attention from the people who
worry about the philosophy of physics.
Uh,
and one of the arguments that people get into over this kind of thing,
which is kind of uh,
uh,
an interesting one people spend a lot of time that people worry about this,
spend a lot of time worrying about is this science a small and by the way thinks
it is,
he thinks that his idea of the these black holes makes a testable prediction,
namely that the current universe should be one that produces the most number of
black holes of any possible universe.
So that if you imagine changing the constants of nature and doing a big
simulation of what the universe would look like with that than any other set of
competent,
uh,
of,
um,
constants of nature would produce fewer black holes,
then this universe does.
Uh,
I think that's actually problematic because most stars in our universe don't
produce black holes.
So you can think,
well,
tweak it up so that they all make black holes.
He then argues that that same tweak changes star formation in such a way that
you actually get fewer starts to work within the first place.
Maybe.
So,
uh,
other people argue that this is totally not science because as soon as you are
invoking universes other than our own,
you've left the realm of science by definition because what is the definition of
science?
It's studying our own university ways,
uh,
that you can actually test.
And by definition,
if you're talking about another universe,
it cannot be tested.
So this isn't science.
Other people say,
well look,
supposing you have some kind of a theory,
uh,
which predict things in our own universe,
which you can observe.
And also the same theory predicts things about the multiverse,
which you can't observe.
If you observe the things in our universe that you can predict correctly,
then that gives you some confidence that the rest of the theory might also be
right.
And so this is a sort of intermediate case where it's mostly science perhaps.
Um,
I have to say,
I personally think it's the wrong question because both sides of this argument
presuppose the idea that if it's science that's good and that if it isn't
science,
you shouldn't be talking about it.
Right?
Uh,
I think that's a problematic,
uh,
point of view just between you,
me and the video camera back there.
Uh,
there's,
uh,
it's just not true that things that aren't science aren't worth thinking about.
Uh,
there's plenty of figs that are thinking about that aren't science in my own
personal view of this argument is that this is one of them.
But this really isn't science.
But I don't care if it's science or not because it's still pretty interesting.
Um,
and I think we should also keep in mind that the border of what science is and
isn't,
has evolved rather quickly over the past hundred years.
And you know this off to be a parrot from what we've talked about in this course
20 years ago,
talking about planets around other stars was complete science fiction.
They did an on star trek but not in the scientific journals.
And this has now as we saw from the example this morning change really very
dramatically,
uh,
40 years ago,
the idea that you would have black holes to actually look at that you could pour
gas into the missy.
What happens was equally,
uh,
equally unscientific a hundred years ago.
The idea that you could say anything scientific about the universe as a whole
was completely preposterous.
That was part of philosophy,
not part of science.
And yet over time,
uh,
all of these things have been kind of a assimilated into science.
And there's no reason to think,
uh,
that the kinds of philosophical musings of about the multiverse might not also
in some way that we can't currently understand,
be pulled into science.
Uh,
and so this whole argument over whether this is a science or not might be
overtaken by events and events are after all,
moving pretty rapidly these days.
This is a golden age of astrophysics because of the instruments we have,
the techniques we've developed,
the theories we have,
uh,
you know,
historians of science a thousand years from now,
we'll say the beginning of the 21st century,
that's when it was all discovered.
And so,
uh,
it's kind of a privilege for me to play some small role in this and to have the
opportunity to talk to you guys about it.
And so I would say,
uh,
whether or not you've learned anything interesting about astrophysics and
whether or not you've learned anything useful about the way science works,
uh,
if you've,
acquired even a fraction of the enthusiasm that I feel for this enterprise,
uh,
then I think our time together has been more or less worthwhile.
Uh,
and so that's all I have to say.
Thank you for your attention.
And we will
[inaudible].